just kind of yeah spur-of-the-moment
decision I just felt like I could do
like one hour of games and why not my
workday is over for today and a couple
of lessons so good stuff but now let's
have some fun games let's do it I'm
going to play viewers but it takes them
over there to get the challenges rolling
so what's going on here on HS get the
starting position the starting screen I
mean but I don't have any any challenges
at the moment I hope I get some let's
see what happens
anybody else streaming it doesn't
display him yeah I know to the chat yeah
I hope get some new guys joining joining
soon those surprise streams they take a
moment to get rolling it needs to be
yeah displayed here on the starting page
and the twitch followers have to kick in
and then yeah it will start ok so one
moment
so let's go PG check okay let's go d6
pre-move one of the pre moves that would
work basically no matter what hello - no
joke chess
let's see six coming what is that word
by the way that's three zero after we
check the town control that some
actually sometimes a little bit tricky
with the viewer challenges the time
controls keep changing sometimes it's
three plus zero three plus two okay I'm
playing a modern defense the g6 base
defense and I always felt like if you
can get c5 and you have chances to get a
really good Sicilian out of that like c5
take and then it's a Sicilian where
white has played some lame moves okay
this is I think a useful tempo to take
yeah good evening to all of you in the
twitch chat I am trying to do what I
mentioned try to try to see against the
porn so it looks like a Sicilian but
White has played short castles Bishop b2
a3 not that this is terrible but it's
also not very dangerous so it's
something that cannot be too threatening
so I have taken and nigev six now he has
to I think take care of the e4 pawn a
little bit
this is hanging maybe just f3 yep just
started yeah pj chick has to speed up it
really has to it's the three minute game
and now already far behind the clock
okay II five him is probably wise idea
so I'll go cover this Bishop really late
join you by the drunken oil if the past
midnight it's really late but I felt
like one hour or so cannot hurt be good
afternoon good afternoon I know you have
a good afternoon because you're 9 hours
or eight hours I think yeah before
time-wise case puts us on the sea farm
definitely well no to the fukes yeah are
you going to twitch account as well
that's cool
okay it seems that white is trying to
play e5
let's go 95 yeah what's it do
five-minute um I think that the the main
way of calculating is just add up the
two the two figures so like 3 + 2 5 2 0
it should not be more than 5 like 5 0 3
2 4 1 these kind of things and now
what's going on here PJ Jinky I can take
on f3 it doesn't look good and my idea
is to actually do a temporary Queen SEC
which would win a piece him okay that
was prevented oh okay
if I take C 3 I'm winning lots of
material ok I'm winning lots of material
here I have 1 2 pieces and look for the
Queen and d4 is hanging Budapest defense
are you tried something with the front
page okay interesting
I'll check what you did noise okay and
let's take this and I probably went on I
will win on time very liked him okay
Peter ship was very quick at the end so
what did she do in the front page our
place with us thank you
that's cool so I'm going to play or this
actually a little bit too long 5 plus 1
but ok it's kind of still reasonable
yeah I need some
Edmonds here right it's not so easy here
do I have to do it
the like matzah do I have to do it by
putting in this text or can I do it with
with clicking probably have to do it
with with texts right somehow I don't I
don't know how to do it I don't see
something to click where with more Redis
yeah it doesn't hurt to have some but
usually the chat is indeed very
civilized
so we'll Knight c3 and I go this retry
to play for later
very good solid setup your back to roll
I tried to play 95 I wonder if that is
actually good night d5 night eggs we
should be 597 it looks a little bit odd
but maybe so good yeah
74 viewers I only saw c41 when I'm happy
with its more if they're only see 41 I
do accept challenges absolutely
make it a blitz challenge something like
3 + 2 3 plus 1 4 0 5 0 3 0 I will take
it
actor is not playing it is kind of
surprising because you almost have to
take only 5 I thought if you move the
bishop I will take C 6 that should be a
little bit better
I'm not disconnected or anything and not
15 + 15 yeah it should add up to 5 yeah
so 4 plus 1 again a 3 2 and no
correspondence chassis yeah I can do the
more thing like here
[Music]
so no bullet yeah
it's generally speaking I would also
play some bullet but the issue is the
the mixture of all the all the different
times that can be sometimes tricky I
should probably do a bullet only session
then if I if we want that so Queen to d2
yeah black is extremely solid yeah then
I need to get emotes I know this was
actually the decision I made 10 minutes
ago
will I invest some time to get the
emotes or do I actually make a stream
and I thought okay I make a quick stream
and then I don't really um I'm not
really much knowledgeable about all that
I felt that the emotes somehow related
to the channel and I was I was thinking
it would be nice to have like me doing
this something like that yeah but but I
haven't really decided and again I'm not
really I had to look up what an e mode
is like a couple of days ago or so I'm
not really well-informed what I'm trying
here is simply to double on the C file
yeah like double here and well if he
plays d4 kicking my night this is really
really open make it 3 + 2 not 3 + 3 2
second increment is is totally enough
and now now I'm almost threatening a
discovery okay
that's a strong move actually it's a
good move how do I get something happen
make something happen here and move the
night it will just be trade Sam this is
extremely extremely sound you can just
challenge but there is a list and I
already 12 challenges issued this is a
very well played game back to Rome I
think it didn't make any any mistakes
very nicely played and also I don't
really have a good idea
one thing that you sometimes can manage
in this kind of position is at the
latest stage you might manage to play f4
g4e 4 and I'm a little bit closer let's
say to moving those pawns and maybe try
to push those two pieces back but this
is something I can only do after some
trades yeah I did compete in the
secondly chest titled arena but I had
some huge connection issues that was the
day of a terrible thunderstorm here in
my area and my connection is not that
great anyway at the moment and with the
Sun thunderstorm I had to simply stop
after 30 minutes and then switch to
cubed saying Magnus I think which it was
kind of enjoyable I would have liked to
play of course but it was great to -
yeah watch Magnus player as strong as he
does it's really really great so what's
going on here
yeah I didn't think this is a little bit
annoying him okay go for invasion not
sure that he needed to do that and one
thing is clear he's a little bit behind
on the clock this might so be it ischium
place some higher rated guys I really
don't mind to do that but I want to yeah
be fair with the with the order the
taking some taking the older challenges
first okay I try to gain some space and
act to or should come on speed up he
really played well but you cannot simply
oliver overstep the time okay and now we
have this scenario that I mentioned I've
got this nice space advantage and I'm
not going to give him some time to
collect his thoughts you should play
quickly now so yeah it's a good in event
I should have thought about this let's
do this it's a temple oh wow f6 I can
also just take right how can there not
so great actually
not as grade I'm not I'm not really into
playing some fun sacrifices which means
nonsense I really try to play good
if possible I mean I will play sharp
openings but not like one age four or
anything that is completely stupid so
let's see me king before I'm not happy
here each five people take I was that
was that was badly played that that any
I played really badly
yeah and he deserves the draw yep and
the draw here for Arturo nicely done
so um let's do it and continue to play
Ford Prefect oops 5-0 you now got the
notification that I went like that
somebody late so four five and we have a
Spanish ship with black like I can
definitely vary the opening so it but I
have to do that it's like consciously if
I'm just playing a game and not think
about it too much
I'm going to play a five it's just my
default mode remove it's probably better
to mix it up a little bit so here we
have a Spanish where he was giving me
the b3 Bishop that's kind of nice of him
the bishop is usually strong on b3 yeah
three minutes three minutes fine
absolutely so castles
not much to you they just have some some
some left
it was a green Roy Roy white bush I
don't know listen yeah well it is in um
in English actually it sounds kind of
funny but it was really really tasty so
what I'm trying to do is a chart to
codify and I'm preparing that
I'm threatening you for now
yes I'm German
you guessed it right the Bender's
supremacy
that's a cool you learn Amy oops
Teague with the bishop now he has a bit
of an issue no less he doesn't have much
confined it's that this this type of t
doesn't doesn't have any caffeine she
must be drunk with milk and from a mock
and not necessarily so what what to do
here I can take on ditch work it take on
c5 this is probably easiest then develop
the Queen and potentially centralize
everything let's do it
that's a new handle right completely new
handle 1500 and the question mark
basically means okay just has registered
what's going on here I can take
yeah I do follow us what's mostly they
are still football a little bit I mean
we're talking about the real football
not American football what you what you
US guys called soccer so take this so I
have a second part of now to pause up
and this is a fairly awkward pinning
situation here on the night the original
football was called soccer okay
okay so how do I do that this is this
potential rook c8 I like rook a - that
would be rook c8 serve not too nice
maybe this one now I know bitter
argument about football vs. okay I think
it's kind of kind of silly but it's
always a little bit weird here that you
have those two those two two terms the
video solving puzzles on chess tempo I'm
not sure really
I have done this for a while but I want
to focus on the stream on streaming on
Twitch and I want to keep it only chess
and not getting another platform in
maybe but I'm not sure how entertaining
it is in a livestream environment this
one
so I can take with the rook probably
it's just to check on c8 not really
dangerous I think and I were taking the
night so
look at this what's so
gee yeah I think there's there's a
question about the German football the
the way the Dortmund strike him over
Obama young against hard to pronounce
actually how he serve trying to get out
of his contract let's say I think this
is a really there's some problems there
with the way those contracts are set up
they really should do something about
this kind of this kind of behavior and I
have no clear idea what they should do
exactly because I'm no lawyer and you're
the guy with the law background but that
I think is kind of unacceptable what
he's doing it's not very surprising I
mean he always yeah acted like you like
you not very mature and same and this is
getting worse so how time I have a
winning this actually like this for the
chick yeah the night is a text and
Queenie one chick that I take the glue
the agents are greedy others they surely
are but I still think it is possible
some of those challenges are a bit too
long you know five plus three and
something yeah I know the in the angel
agents are greedy but something
sometimes the players are just so plain
damn stupid yeah if they just would be
somewhat yeah somewhat okay they would
manage their own finances there there
they have been excellent athletes or a
sports person that say
managed to handle their own finances for
example for for time I think Formula one
champion Sebastian Vettel they never had
a manager did all the financial stuff
for himself which is actually quite a
good idea sometimes because well you
don't pay those bozos plopper who
supposedly yeah counsel you
hmm five plus eight that's a bit long
okay so let's see what happens here
Oliver head Oh played solid opening
gather the London system cannot win do
you form I'm going to tribe
yeah be true there was always 95 stuff
this is actually tricky my queen has to
suffer a little bit
yeah it really gets pushed around but
it's a central pawn yeah I think
Lawrence Trent was the manager of
Haryana Khurana I don't think he does
that anymore but I'm not really very
knowledgeable there you can grab a set
upon it's almost always worth doing so
if you don't see a clear refutation it's
difficult to drum up a game with right
yeah you have no pawn controller in the
center anymore mm-hmm
what is he doing there just kick it away
yeah white knight has to go back
I wonder 95 that looks like a decent
enough move but threatens here at
friends to take this will you watch the
Winter Olympics that's a good question
hmm well maybe a bit it depends some
things I like to watch from time to time
I'm not quite sure about about this
because of the time difference
yeah it's Korea it's a quite a
substantial time difference
mmm chaos 45
[Music]
he was the center um would you be the
second for you top 10 player well I
don't think I could help them well I
actually think you can maybe I could in
some cases but it I think it's if you
look at some some things they are made
for example Nakamura has gone a second
which is not super high rated generating
opening ideas maybe I could do that I
don't know I've never tried okay yeah
just be six kick it away I don't know I
didn't really do much to fix the
streaming problems I just restarted the
Ruta and it helped a little bit all I
all I need to what I can do at the
moment quince is six and made here that
would be nice yeah being am being a
second to those top players I think is
this really really tough work yeah you
have to put in hours and hours and hours
I mean I hope they pay to get paid well
because I feel it's it's really really
tough I'm taking
I am I am listened to a podcast on the
perpetual chest podcast I don't know if
you know that it's a really great
podcast may I'm done by Ben Jonson and
Ben Jonson is a like a candidate master
my master level play who does a really
nice chess podcast and he had he had
Luke friend really on and when really
far for a while was second to bloody Mac
ramnik and family said that he simply he
learned to I mean he said it was very
interesting very challenging but also
like I don't want to do it anymore yeah
you kind of hate your life after a while
because you have to work so hard and I
can imagine especially in the context of
a bland championship match it must be
extremely tough work yeah I was pretty
[Music]
quick and giving up the exchange and I
wonder if that was a clever decision but
I think it is okay I got Bishop before
him it's hard to believe that he can
survive at him here all this
check teenage - hmm
oh don't see you win
don't see one which is kind of weird
where is the wind
right Queenie to
between you two of course into the
points do the job took me a while yeah
and Oliver hello resigned so it's a
really long list okay best bad practice
I decline it's a bit too long five plus
two also too long let's keep it maybe I
should actually do this with bullet yeah
so
I have played e5 again sorry I want to
vary it a little bit and I do this like
an autopilot I go 105
yeah 4 plus 2 again is a bit long and
let's keep it 5 in the sum of those two
should be 5
that's a good question here by gdb 11 to
6 maybe one of the experienced guys he
can can help maybe only one time control
for the challenges could be an idea 30
second bullet no let's not do that
that's a bit too hectic really from him
especially late in the day what advice
do you have for beginners well I think I
know it sounds extremely simple but you
should actually do what you like to do I
know it sounds very basic but there is
lots of advice and some things do make a
little bit more sense than others you
know if they let's say advise you to do
something like study openings 20 moves
deep that doesn't make all that much
sense and so if you enjoy doing it it's
still better than doing absolutely
nothing you will learn some stuff I
think it makes more sense to focus on on
tactics and calculation absolutely does
but if you instead enjoy looking at
master games more or just play more do
it it will help it will definitely help
well a question here I think if the
benoni is played at the GM level on a
regular basis as a repertoire for sure
for sure the model mean only that is I
don't really think that would be Nonie
Bishop g5 was an idea and I wanted to
prevent it nobody should be six hey
there's a good question any advice for
an eleven hundred rated who wants to
become world champion in a year's time
um I don't think you can do it in a year
that is probably a little bit too quick
the main issue is that you have to go
over to through the candidates and so on
that takes a while but maybe you can do
it in two years so if I cancel in 94
it's going to be a little bit annoying
this one may be ideal phobias playing a
good game here absolutely I played a
slightly risky line admittedly
yeah I kept the king of the center for a
really long time but it's always a bit
tricky to play for him play for a little
bit more than state equality in like in
the exchange we're here with black shop
play stronger opponents even if you lose
is that some good advice and yeah it is
it is it is okay but yeah I know that he
was joking I try to just keep a deadpan
face and um it is definitely a good idea
to play stronger opponents but I think
you should do it
they should not be totally out of reach
this is what can be extremely
frustrating yeah if you if you like
let's say let's say okay I'll give you
an example if I would play in Tata Steel
it wouldn't make much sense I mean it
was this those guys would be too far
away from me like 300 point difference
in most games and maybe you get a couple
of drawers or something yeah but that's
it it's just too much of a difference
it's the same if you put in 1700 player
yeah with many 2,100 so then they won't
score that much so usually a difference
like 100 to 200 points is good yeah so I
played b6 because maybe Knight c5 or
Bishop c5 was an idea and I'm really
happy to get this and gain more space
white might be able to play d4 next
yeah that's actually really true before
I need to play C form
yeah the Scandinavian defense is not a
bad opening I wouldn't advise to play it
every single game but there's nothing
fundamentally wrong with it so let's go
here and prevent white going D form yeah
white was a bit better developed still
still ischium
it seems that the club
the drunken lawyers club has many young
talents nice
king/queen g3 a really good game nearby
idea phobia wow that's really annoying
he's got two seconds I just see that I'm
sorry that makes a little bit simpler he
won't win in two seconds but the
position yeah I also do give over the
board lessons yes not that often I mean
he has to be like in the area but
currently I'm not taking any new
students anyway let's go with silky
McNuggets I'll play something else yeah
play a form what is the biggest ego jump
of one of my students um okay maybe get
into the Kings gambit yeah something
like roughly 300 to 400 points it
depends how you count but it's it's not
this kind of thing is this is always
tough to evaluate because if you let's
say in this case the student that
improved that much is a junior a junior
player and at this age they improved
from quicker and this is something I'm
very sure she would have improved quite
a bit three to four points roughly
eighteen months or something um she
would have improved anyway it's like
it's it's easy to easy to do for for
teach them but it's much more difficult
if you have like a 40 year old or so
it's just a different thing so I'm
really happy with the progress of some
of the students that are like in their
30s gained like 100 points 80 points
this is this is already a sizable
sizable jump at this age especially when
they have limited time and the time
spent is not changing for some
particular reason they're like if you
winter like I don't know if you win the
lottery and have unlimited money to play
tournaments
it's a different situation but if you
basically try to play better shares
while working there are limits to what
you can do so um what am I doing here I
think this is actually a fairly good
position for black don't like my
position all that much yes I will point
down okay that's the that's the Kings
gambit for you I don't like to be a pawn
down
yeah and then the chess improvement
sometimes not easily let's say described
in points points gained you can have
longer periods of time where you
actually improve as a player can a
better player but you don't actually
gain points then that can easily easily
happen I've had those times when I was
really working hard on my game like
Xavier didn't gain points and at some
bad games that when went wrong still um
I did improve I was getting getting
better at chess somehow but it didn't
translate into into wins right away it
sometimes just take time until you
completely yeah absorb let's say every
single piece of information that you
learn okay I'm picking the Queen and I
would really like to get the pawn back
I'm really not a great gambit player yes
yeah at least with such a fishy gambit
it's a bit fishy in the Kings gambit
just just what it is I can't taking this
okay I need to make sure that I'm not
blundering the rook that's kind of
important so let's move it move the
bishop I mean it still feels kind of
came and threw the Kings gambit is a
solid opening compared to the Helloween
gambit that is true but compared to the
Helen encampment like everything is kind
of safe I wonder this is a safer move
probably not but I want to get get open
files open France at night f 595 is made
let's not do that but I can go rookie
for it looks kind of cave
probably going to H 3m no going back
okay
I can't do another five I think it looks
it looks a bit dangerous for black I'm
not sure that I'm threatening much maybe
the group g1 in Bishop g5 if this can be
a plan at least let's do it
how do you play against the Scandinavian
hmm yeah it is actually
the issue with playing against the
Scandinavian with Queen g5 it's that
there are those oh I take that there are
those three Queen moves and actually the
theory is a little bit different you
cannot play the same thing against all
three moves you have to really look at
them look at them as as separate lines
and there are quite some important
differences there so you have to invest
a bit of time to get something I was
surprised
it's actually a very fairly good opening
okay so it's kind of annoying here yeah
I think I'm just giving giving him a
little bit back and okay
didn't take McQueen surprisingly yeah
Queen f5 my upcoming repertoire just
goes for d4 Knight has freed Bishop c4
white is keeping an advantage there it
it doesn't really matter any line is
kind of okay from like it's not totally
terrible really not two plus three is a
very uncommon time control three plus
two is kind of normal
what to play against a bird opening yet
you just should probably depends if
you're a default player you can just
play em yeah I know it's a it's a viable
time control I can play something with
d5 if you are default player that's
relatively easy you just handle it like
a Dutch defense and tempo isn't all that
relevant 185 I wouldn't recommend what
can actually grab the pawn I know that I
didn't do that
last game because the mmm sorry because
the King's gambit was too tempting sorry
my voice is a little bit of 2 + 8 is a
funny tap or draw sorry
okay I wish it was a mouse slip yeah I
was just thinking hmm there should be
seven that's a little bit on them on I
am I don't know creative side yeah I
just tried to play me from get every
possible center pawn involved in three
maybe a three is a bit lame I was just I
just want to prepare this you know if
you play increment blitz and you end up
with more time then you started with
yeah like here I'm above two to two
minutes I always feel like you deserve
more points than just one but probably
this is a uncommon way of seeing it it
actually happens to me quite often now
quite often it's a lot but but sometimes
in three plus two hours sometimes end up
with more than three minutes
I have really nice pieces
yes black there's a question there by
it's tough to read them because such a a
dark font yeah you have to you have to
just what to what white is doing it's
just a big difference like if they go
efore d4 c4 it's totally totally
different and everything has to be
studied separately so what to do he
actually I can take twice actually if he
takes I probably go 936 doesn't do that
okay I can still go 96 what's the best
chess engine yeah I'm not sure really
I'm not I am NOT a not an expert on the
different on the different engines I use
stock fish because it's free so yeah
thanks for the donation silky McNuggets
there are many more Komodo and all kinds
of engines some versions of Houdini and
well I use stop which because again it's
free I don't have to worry about things
like what version to get should I invest
this will there be an update I just
update when they release a new version
and so on it's easy to handle
okay this is a nice way of finishing it
some good pieces they have made next
yeah thanks for the game show you Balu
II probably yes stockfish 9 is coming up
I read dad they are always going always
developing and new versions so yeah
thanks for subscribing to roof anillo so
if a fab from Switzerland okay I can do
what can I do here I could I could try
for the bank oh but they play so much
Bishop f4 193 and stuff you don't get it
so often
yeah thanks for accepting he says I'm
happy too it's a long list of three
yeah there are many very many good books
around that's a huge difference to let's
say 30 years ago like 30 35 years ago
when I 35 35 is a bit much yeah but like
30 years ago when I started with chess
there weren't that many that many books
around simply back then I would just go
to my local bookstore
it was pre-internet era and I would just
buy every book that there was ain't it
you you you you were finished pretty
soon with everything that there was
because there were many books and
nowadays there's so much around most of
the time I advise to rather look at more
modern books so um I I don't really know
why people still yeah recommend my
system by nimzowitsch
this is just like it's kind of a pet
peeve of mine why would anybody he was a
book that's 100 years old where most of
it is just not correct and I don't know
there's so many so many mistakes and
them it's not even well explained I mean
I know it has huge historical value in
terms of chess history and I really
enjoy chess history but it has
historical value and not much
instruction William how many books to
have on me a couple hundred I think I've
gotten ripped rid of many years two
years ago before I was moving simply to
get new place new space
yes some of the names of which concepts
as of course when it sounds like he was
writing nonsense
and I'm not saying that it's just that
it is just there are many more like
current books that explain the same
concepts and in a better way
so here the main issue and miss is the
white white spending so much time I have
Bishop a 695 I can go on those slide
squares
he was allowing the capture of the
LightSquared bishop and that improves my
chances on this these squares I can I
can take it
I should see for comes a track I think I
hear actually from that c4 would be nice
but he's got no b3 b3 has actually
hmm folk say you're planning to to build
a chess website yeah message me would be
very interested to learn what you think
what you what you want to do I'm kind of
falling asleep yeah not making a
decision that's not good
okay let's do this
what positional play books do you
recommend for the e4 player
interesting an interesting way to
approach that would be to get the
there's a two-volume work on campus
strategic wins by the Hungarian chess
teacher trainer karoli cup of strategic
wins it's separated into two errors I
think from 1960 whatever to 85 and and
after that and you know Karpov was a
fantastic efore player and he only
stopped to play one e4 once he
recognized that Kasparov was just too
strong in the night off
but cup of had fantastic games in the
70s with one e4 so that is an
interesting way of approaching this
those books are great anyway yeah thanks
for playing
you have far FA fab 187 okay yeah Mickey
Adams is also a player to study when you
want to check out one e4 and want to
play in a more in a more strategic
fashion let's say it's my favorite book
not related to chess and why oh wow
[Music]
no I wouldn't you would need to think
about that
how much longer will I be playing I
don't have a clear plan but I've got
quite a good view account close to 200
people so does that work looks
looks a little bit fishy it looks a bit
fishy what white is doing here somehow
on that diagonal here
oh no I take it sapiens is a is a no my
system is not a bad book I think that
that sounds to be the debts
misunderstanding it was an excellent
book and groundbreaking for the time but
it's like almost 100 years old this is
the thing things have happened yeah in
the in the mean time so I'm not saying
it's a terrible book it just like it's
just outdated yeah if you if you
nowadays I want to learn about and I
know neuroscience you're not going to
get a book that is 50 years old it it's
easy to trash talk about my system
because it's sometimes really weird
anyway sapiens is a great read the
bender supremacist says sapiens is that
is that the Harari book not sure about
the English trial this is an excellent
book I felt was very interesting to read
very um it kind of makes you think about
things
yeah here I'm a pawn up and I wonder
Center come on which is really nice
that's Cordy 5 that looks like a good
temperament taking this yeah I see I see
your point as a there's a statement that
I would books on programming could be
useful there that I see the point
leeches is banning chest or comm
streamers no air that sounds weird okay
so what's going on here I think I'm
shaking that looks like a good way of
doing it
thanks for the strong bad bishops and
this is funny saying best bishops
protect the pawns this is something this
is really one of my favorite Chesham
yeah chess quotes that bad bishops
protect good points I really like that
it's ads of course it's it strongly
cheat but this is a really cool quote
okay here I'm going to double on the
default double on the default
trying to catch white here in the center
any kind of chess books one should avoid
booth and I don't think you can make
such a general general statement they
are always there's always the odd book
where fields that are really necessary
is that good
I don't know there are there's really
lots of lots of stuff on the market and
it looks like there should be something
on the back right right and Bobby
Fischer teaches chess isn't that the
book they're just about the back ranked
mate
it's really weird
um yeah books recommend one was that any
suggestion for a 1500 player
um I think 1500 it depends a little bit
on a little bit on what you're looking
for and a little bit on how you approach
your studies for example what is pretty
good material otherwise you support
training books yeah in German they have
this funny name at each bone and they
are they have very good but they are
somewhat dry they're dry to study so the
th pong books on the use of training
books I think they are not really
suitable for kids let's say yeah to just
let them study on their own this is
funny
the hard to see if what the made just a
night move but it's good it's good study
material for adults Forex
the use of workbooks they are not
flawless of course nothing is but
no I don't think there's a good book
about capo style wooden backup I don't
think Karpov has ever written a chest
book they all go straight as it's all
it's all ghost writing stuff ain't made
the art of a chicken chest I think I
think and I looked at them yeah the
books tend to be the you support books
same with Gretzky because they tend to
be a bit boring yeah they're the they
are not written in a very let's say
entertaining or captivating style but
it's good material that's him
so I played Tosh French tirage Oh the
strongest player ever played a classical
blitz or blitz game against over the
board that's interesting I'm really not
sure about blitz part what was the
strongest blitz player I played against
a probably rule F ski Sega Rublev ski is
his highest rating was 2700 I think and
the classical chess I played a couple of
players that were close to 2670 and so
on and a very good score against those
people I always somehow I always had
white and it helps
that game against wróblewski that blitz
game was actually very memorable because
that was played in the German team blitz
championship so fairly interesting the
event in itself the funny thing was wow
how can you accept mr. Damon's isn't
there this sir must be made somewhere
where's the maid I can't win the rook
but yeah so why was that game memorable
so we started playing and mm black yam
and he plays a scotch opening as he
always does wróblewski is the words
probably a foremost expert on the scotch
and we play and we play we play like
maybe 15 moves and then we wonder I am
all those people are standing close to
our game because they were like it was
full of people and we were wondering
what's going on and then I noticed for
some reason we didn't start the clock
that was completely ridiculous yes so
you have two experienced players play
and we didn't start the clock yeah and
it's um and then yeah we didn't know
what to do here and the arbiter was
coming and we agreed that we simply put
the clock back on to five minutes and
and basically we were continuing from
that position but we both had five
minutes which was probably okay yeah
roughly it was just crazier than it that
it would happen in such a game thanks
for the donation Brandon you know the
funniest part was really that we were
recognizing not the clock we were
recognizing those people around us then
we were like what's going on here yeah
and then then then we saw the BET the
clock wasn't running I was really funny
yeah what I also held generally speaking
what is useful to learn chess and
improve yes - yeah
pick pick some pick some player it
happens almost automatically pick some
player that you somehow enjoy watching
yeah that where you think okay this is
this person has an a really cool opening
plane he plays whatever it does not
necessarily need to be all that rational
yeah your decision but just pick some
somebody you basically model in your
game after and this is an interesting
way of doing it of course you're not
going to play as well as cards or
Aronian or whatever but it's a it's a
cool thing to do like copy copy openings
for example it's it's what I did for
example Nevin has started I always liked
and what what Karpov did and what what
what Fischer did and so on and in some
in some cases it's just just great to
have somebody to look after and that you
can can study and it stopped it's not a
bad advice I think I can't going back
it doesn't really matter who you pick
yeah I mean it's again it happens
automatically it's probably a no similar
to another the sports team that you're
supporting and that's not a real
rational reason they're sometimes yeah
I'm up tons of materially I think it's a
it's a full look
yeah Larson's best games is a really
great book I recently recommended that
in in in the book review that I posted I
think Christmas time so he tries to get
to my night
I try to somehow not lose it it's not
easy
it's pushed the pawns
I don't think you can stop it yeah you
need to challenge me of course um that's
the way to play me even though there is
a long distance so it will be tricky if
you now do the challenge involving
turkeys will be made meet in the corner
nice one so who else is on
deviator I have to really decline the
Horde challenge
I don't play variants really don't want
so deviator youichi
okay
doesn't play that doesn't that does not
help okay I'm going to board that you
can always reach challenge
Twinkletoes I had a funny one funny name
okay let's go see forum
of course a fantastic book that I did
not mention in my latest book review is
the live and games of half child this is
so basically everybody everybody's
favorite book and it's very
understandable it's really great stuff
the status of the chasuble
efore series um yeah it's um almost
finished it it depends a bit on tomorrow
and day after tomorrow when I get to
that's a weird sentence because I have
to think about the game phone with him
it depends on some lawn chairs things
that I might have to do not have to do
it will yeah I probably screwed it up
here as screwed to move water up Tony
and so then II for repertoire is it's
close to finished but but it will not be
released like next week or so because we
will also have video for that and this
takes a while to record
yeah I don't like this I don't like this
I mean I can actually win a pawn but
looks a little bit yeah I think it's
okay
[Music]
yeah I grab the porn now i reaiiy don't
have the de grandmas no and energy for
was possible but i'm still upon up I
don't have for I am home stir well after
getting the title I scored a couple of
more it took a long time to score the
third one but after that I made it I
made really a lot lots of them no you
cannot catch it I am known for GM noms
they are really a lot more difficult so
I'm quickly opening this up
so um I do I should not blunder the rock
you know black it needs to try to block
this d5 pawn otherwise it's too much
there will be emotes yes there will be I
think currently with the current
subscriber count I can only have one or
two I think but I have to look into that
again yeah I did not really I'm not
really informed about all those things
that much yeah I will use this day now
no I should win win one pawn
hmm yeah I need a nonsense emote
certainly do I probably need some I
probably need some advice on those emo
things I have no clue what to do with
that I know what I want to do now this
is also hanging the artwork and then the
twitchtv artwork that was easy then
awesome that's a professional photograph
of me and then I used the Prisma app or
prism lion-o prismo I know it's called
prism on the German the German term you
just for altering for changing photos it
looks pretty neat for something that was
stunning in two minutes
so a lot lot lot love okay we are 38
unless this is crazy
[Music]
really crazy
Oh age 3 wow I forgot about that I think
I can take what I was thinking and what
I wanted to ask and what about them what
about streaming for a longer period of
time is that ever done here on playing
on niches like doing a marathon dream of
a stream of 12 hours or 24 hours things
like that is that has that ever been
done it could be interesting
I'm just winning this I think
2024 hours Wow
so let's let's get the Queen out of the
house along Wow they have been quite
quite a couple of 24 hours dream small
now I think you tween 24 hours in one go
wow that's really really tough I think I
could definitely do 24 hours
you know I have from like yeah let's say
five-minute breaks every now and then I
think that's not a big big deal you need
some restroom breaks and yeah I need to
get new tea and stuff so as I'm
comfortably comfortably a piss-up it's
definitely it's definitely tough to do I
think I remember are you still on
Brendan I'm still on I think I think you
are I mean we probably both remember the
charity stream it must been this a
couple of years ago but it was extremely
tough
yeah I know I'm a bit I'm a bit of a
boring guy I attend to trade trade stuff
when I material up
yeah Australian well via that the
charity stream yeah 2012-2013 that's
probably probably right
I could have captured the Queen really
it's possible I'm not completely ruling
that out okay thanks for the game
American stream they're probably there
are bad for your health
okay fishy fishy you beat me yesterday
yeah that's not yeah so um I've got
white now I've got right now I lost a
king's gambit Adelaide counter gambit
yesterday
[Music]
I could swim at interesting locations
like the local gym yes yeah I could
stream at the local gym yeah maybe and
in sports the tire that'd probably be
extremely popular like in muscle shirts
yeah it would be probably great yes I
can play against the isolated pawn
whoosh Oh interesting play about a fishy
regime okay but don't wanted to take
them interesting play now I actually
threatened to take on b7 yeah sit-ups
for every blonde piece and then I would
probably be close to to a heart attack
pretty soon as I can take it right
just one upon him ninety form the rupee
eight is this annoying I think I'm just
getting the Queen back have you haven't
been to the States
yeah about the own name for a very short
period of time I've been to New York for
four or five days in 1999 actually
fairly long time ago so night to be five
no I don't want you to take my brush up
really don't
[Music]
that's cool look you won
nice defending it as well actually yeah
the metrics the metrics are actually
watched in New York you know in New York
cinema
that was really nice
yeah I mean I can take them seven and
now Queen takes g7 right isn't that
winning
yes I think so no doing a push-up for
every donated or euro I don't know yeah
neutral meaning was denied entry to the
United States the fish says revenge yeah
yeah good games though yes I have played
against Nakamura a couple of times and I
didn't scroll that well but there's one
one nice nice win dead ahead
playing Jonah here in the French defense
my school against Nakamura has something
like you know maybe five out of fifty or
something but the one winner had yeah is
actually in all the channel which is
which is nice I watch out nine f6 Bishop
takes b7 and this is trick is catching
so many people
yeah I'm just winning a pawn
it's made it's may be true aware that
this is not objectively the best
variation but it is fairly okay for what
you can try to play for natraj advantage
even if they don't stumble into that and
you always have this possibility that
you can catch people like this don't
think there's anything wrong with
playing this variation okay I'm a pawn
up I don't have a good square for the
Queen anyway so the trade is fine
yeah most of my games against Nakamura
one when I wasn't having the channel
actually because my youtube channel was
started in 2011 and I was always playing
on the ICC and at the time Nakamura
wasn't playing on the ICC or that often
anymore he was mostly focusing at the
time and breaking into the absolute top
of the world and didn't play so much
online blitz anymore
he was playing all other time tons of
games ready some years before that like
in the mid 90s mid nineties the mid 2000
like 2002 2 or 3 4 or 5 and so on he
played all the time to recommend for
1900 rating players yeah it's always
tough to say everybody needs some
something else I guess that's not a
simple recipe so what to do here
yeah my development is not that great I
think I get the King into the centre car
park ask are you friends with Kings
crusher yeah I think you can call it
like that we don't have that much
contact in the recent like two or three
years but we chat from time to time a
[Music]
good job here by Joan I'm defending this
quite well I'm torn up but it's my
development is not great and he's
playing this okay
hmm yeah good job he's defending well
but the time will be a problem for him I
still have more than two minutes on the
clock
and it's not speeding up its increment
though so he should not lose on time
good question who would have bet on in10
bullet Nakamura or thousand I think I
would go with Nakamura them
he's so insanely quick but then that
that that that's a close one I think
that probably won't be very that would
be very closely contested so let's see
how to win this but actually that sure
how to do it
[Music]
that I can take young Magnus is quick
it's not like he wouldn't have a chance
absolutely that that will be competitive
yeah but yeah idea hit me it's actually
a bullet challenge so let's get a lot of
he's around actually this is a g4 is
slightly fishy but also going to be
interesting after just two bullet time
control what button was that
yeah good night to the drunken no I have
to go to university again tomorrow right
selfie how to win this actually chick is
not so easy to go back
yeah I mean Bishop c5 I know but there
is there's this mate okay yeah thanks
all play for the game idea hit me okay
Nagila how long is this stream on by the
way I have no clue it doesn't tell me I
think we are close to two hours yeah I
think I'll do some more minutes but not
super long anymore I have to I have to
get up in roughly 1700 hours so
yeah yeah I traded off the dark square
bishop and now I'm trying to put pawns
on dark squares let's do it d5 and Agee
long I threatened this now a for
freezing the whole Queen side so be
three years is what I probably should do
so that a 4 can be answered with before
it goes before merely that that is a
very slow way of developing I'd seem I
try to open this up and maybe get a
quick development out of it
I am Not sure now that the thing about
it probably not the greatest move might
be one is a very retro movie I go back I
don't think it helps I try this put some
pressure on the pawn Knight c3 rook c8
it looks okay
weights d5 what
got the five
and again
now you cannot beserk in in nan arena
games you can of course play quickly and
I'm doing this year but it's um it only
makes sense in the context of those
tournaments really so I'm trying to
double on the seafoam
that's difficult now they cannot move
this as c1 is completely hanging and I'm
threatening d5 and I'm trying to take so
I think I'm winning even more material
just should drop a piece don't see how
he saves the piece nope
yeah trying desperately to save them
save it but I think it's right yeah and
he resigned Nagila thanks for the game
so see I am TS if five plus one is a bit
too long actually but it's so still not
correspondence chess oh we're fourth
yeah I don't I don't like e5 over that
much but this is interesting I was a
mouse clip of us bishop chief oh he's
right I think this isn't that great
actually
hey it's okay in a blitz game you can
play that but objectively I think it's
not that great
even one your form is quite decent yeah
yeah this is a from from gambit mainline
there's g5 there's nine f6 but III
really don't know it yeah thanks for the
mmm LED lights and then chat as well
yeah I have absolutely no clue how this
is played I just feel like I'm caught
down for nothing
you play 94 and win most games yeah
that's probably the way to do it
yeah it's already too late for any
direct sacrificial attacks and when I
can just play for for good good central
control and so on
that looks weakened looks are weakening
well he didn't he did not really need to
do that
lining this up
hmm that's a good move so Queen d6 isn't
that effective anymore
yeah I don't know if H 5 H 4 is really
that easy to play
yeah he might be watching the street
that says definitely true this is not
very subtle but it could work
yeah he has to cover h2 I don't think he
can allow me to check them I would be
quite surprising yeah okay
the main thing that this is actually
clearing a square okay
let's still do that but now Bishop
before Queen takes f6 is the thing my
queen doesn't have all that many squares
actually not so easy
that's so easy I mean okay why do I
probably take this now or does he have
anything else I don't see it
fool what's he doing you know he played
the move that I expected at the end we
had the rookies hanging so loses a bit
more time came I want to keep this out
of the game I think I'm going to play
one more game after that so it's a
roughly two hour stream and it's it's
really getting close to a time where I
should go to bed so
[Music]
yep take a couple of stings Queen d2 as
well Queen no Queen e2 problem Episode
III 1/2 okay
yeah this is move wins apiece King takes
take the Queen like here him
yeah thanks for the game see IMT so the
bender supremacy will be the final game
yeah let's go night of three again who
is going for she go in style setup Wow
f6 that looks risky yeah I would play
the odd bullet game but this is a final
game for the stream after two hours I'm
attacking this are you going to really
go back to f8
[Music]
right answer that pork that pork
some sub-optimal moves have been played
yeah I guess so
Oh Queen 84 I actually have him I had
this before
this is my head we need the nonsense
emote yeah thanks for the game the
bender supremacy okay I hope you all
enjoyed this little surprise
late night stream I'll be back soon with
a new stream um not exactly sure when
this will happen
um maybe tomorrow or sometime but it
depends on some other factors thanks a
lot for watching I'll be back soon bye
bye